get more reaction on this now the
barrister who's been analyzing coven
rules adam wagner from dowty street
chambers good to talk to you adam um
if it's clear that this event did happen
as it would suggest
were rules broken
um
it sounds to me like they probably were
um
at the time you weren't allowed to be
outside of the place you were living
without a reasonable excuse
and the only reasonable excuse that
could probably apply here would be that
you needed to be there for work um but
this seemed to be an after work party
a social gathering bring your own booze
i don't think civil servants you know
work with booze
and you know i just think it sounds a
lot like a social gathering exactly the
kind of social gathering which the
government itself don't forget it was
cabinet office that were making the
rules at the time with the prime
minister the government itself was
consistently telling everybody don't
have social gatherings so how they could
then argue this was reasonably necessary
for work
i just can't see it
and the problem we've heard the prime
minister defending other gatherings
saying you know it's his own garden but
let's just be clear the prime minister
and and his wife
okay to be there yes perhaps one other
person at a distance yes
100 members of staff no
yeah so so the prime minister and his
wife would not be breaking that rule
because they weren't outside of their
home they were in their own garden which
was part of the home um but according to
these rules but obviously
inviting lots and lots of people to your
home even if it does form part of the
workplace for a social gathering is is
not something which
put it this way if you had asked the
government at the time if you'd asked
matt hong kong called the prime minister
at a press conference i want to invite
100 people to my garden it's you know an
after work gathering social gathering
with alcohol they would have you know
blown their tops they would have said
absolutely not that is
exactly what we don't want people to be
doing um we want to discourage
gatherings rather than encourage
gatherings even if technically it's um
you know it's that people are coming
after work so well they work together so
i really cannot see how this is
defensible from the government
perspective
in theory if this did happen who could
be prosecuted over it
would it be the homeowner would it be
boris johnson or would it be the person
who sent the email and organized the
party
well well the most obvious people to be
prosecuted would be the people who
attended um because they were the ones
that were outside of their home without
a reasonable excuse
and there is an also a possibility this
has come up in um one of my cases that
i'm asking for the women who organized
the the vigil for sarah everard and the
police the metropolitan police in their
case threatened them with being
prosecuted under the serious crime act
as accessories to other people attending
that gathering
so in theory although i haven't seen it
done that could you know the prime
minister would be all the uh the person
who sent the email out could be an
accessory to other people's crime but i
think the most obvious target would be
the people who attended and they would
uh
according to the metropolitan police's
approach they would first probably be
given fixed penalty notices of 60 pounds
and if they didn't pay potentially
charged but that's quite a long way down
the line because at the moment the
metropolitan police have said they don't
generally investigate retrospective
offenses
and
you as you say involved in in some of
these prosecutions how many are going
through the courts at the moment for for
these kind of breaches around that time
so there's there's have been quite a lot
of prosecutions for breaches around that
time and i think generally those are
probably where people haven't paid their
fixed penalty notices and has been a
sort of automatic trigger almost
to um being charged
i don't know of
cases where the metropolitan police or
any police force have charged so long
after an event because they've only just
found out about the facts of it but
that's not to say they couldn't i don't
think there's any legal reason why they
couldn't do that
and they'll be feeling a lot of pressure
um i'm also involved in a case which is
potentially challenging the metropolitan
police
refusing to investigate these these
issues so that they'll you know the
pressure will be there and we'll see
what happens
how much pressure do you think that
there is now on the police given that
there appears to be
evidence we are photographing evidence
of a gathering on the 15th of may and we
have this email now
uh of from the 20th and at the same time
there's this investigation going on
inside downing street will the police
and the internal investigators be
speaking do you think
well as i i mean i've only read what
what's been on the news and apparently
they are liaising whatever that means
but i think that what
the the government has said the cabinet
office have said that any evidence of
criminal um offenses which sue grey
unearths would need will be sent to the
metropolitan police and at that point
the investigation will be paused because
obviously the economy shouldn't he can't
prejudice a police investigation and if
i were
um a betting man which i'm not i would
think there may be come a point in the
next few days where sue gray has to um
suspend her in her investigation because
it will be coming close or it'll be
getting to the point where this looks a
lot like criminal offences and she will
have to pass on the evidence to the
metropolitan police who may not then do
anything with it they may not prosecute
who knows but i
i my suspicion is sue grey's
inquiry may not conclude
so sorry just before we let you go
just to confirm the facts around that so
you think that if if sue gray were to
uncover what what she believed were
wasn't legal activity she would be due
to bound to pass it over to the police
which yeah absolutely because they said
publicly that's what that's what she
will do and they've and i've seen an
email that was um published in one of
the newspapers that was sent around from
sugray to to civil servants saying don't
destroy any evidence and if criminal
evidence of criminal conduct um arises i
will have to or i may have to spend my
investigation so
i think that is that that is certainly
the case she will not want to be
um
it to be said later down the line that
her interviews or her actions prejudiced
the ultimate police investigation so if
the police want to get involved or she
thinks they should do
then i think that that's where that's
that will be the next step
interesting stuff barrister adam wagner
good to talk to you thanks for joining
us and skye thank you
let's go look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
cloud and rain will spread across the
south today leaving it mostly fine for
the rest of the week but with a risk of
fog and frost south wales and central
and southern england will start the
afternoon mild and murky without breaks
of light rain most other places will be
dry and sunny if cooler but northern and
western scotland will see a few blustery
showers later more of wales and the
north midlands will brighten but further
south it'll stay rather gray and damp
into the evening meanwhile the showers
in the far northwest will become
isolated
tonight low cloud and patchy light rain
should clear across the south to leave
starry skies for much of england wales
and ireland
an extensive frost is likely there with
some rural fog forming further north it
will be milder and cloudier
wednesday will bring plenty of sunshine
to the south and east once the morning
fog patches lift and there will be more
cloud in the northwest which will bring
drizzly rain to some coasts and hills
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
this is sky news today coming up we'll
take you live to the house of commons
where labour is to ask an urgent
question following allegations of
downing street parties during lockdown
[Music]
the opposition angela rainer taking you
back to the house of commons in this
urgent question thank you mr speaker to
ask the prime minister
to make a statement on reports of events
held
in the downing street garden on the 20th
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much mr speaker
both the prime minister and i
came before
the house in december to set out the
details of the investigation
being led by the cabinet office into the
allegations of gatherings
in downing street
and the department for education in
november and december of 2020
as i did then
mr speaker i apologize again
unreservedly
for the upset that these allegations
have caused
the prime minister has asked for an
investigation to take place and the
terms of reference for the
investigations
that are underway have already been
published
i can't hear what's being said it's
quite it's quite obvious it is not the
prime minister so we don't need to keep
asking that question so please can i
hear what the minister's got to say he's
got he's got the tough job as it is
don't make it harder for him come on
minister mr speaker the prime minister
has asked for an investigation to take
place
and the terms of reference for the
investigations that are underway
have already been published and
deposited in the libraries of this house
and impacted both houses
the investigations are now being led by
sue gray
she is the second permanent secretary at
the cabinet office and the department
for leveling up and of course she is a
former director general of propriety and
ethics the
government has committed
to publishing the findings of the
investigation
and providing these to parliament in the
normal way
the terms of reference set out
that where there are credible
allegations relating to other gatherings
it is open for those to be investigated
and i can confirm to the house mr
speaker that this includes the
allegations relating to the 15th and
20th of may 2020
it will establish the facts
and if wrongdoing is established
there will be requisite disciplinary
action taken
as with all internal investigations if
evidence emerges of what was potentially
a criminal offence the matter would be
referred to the metropolitan police
and the cabinet office's work may be
paused
matters relating to the adherence of the
law are as ever matters for the
metropolitan police to investigate and
the cabinet office will liaise with them
as appropriate as i'm sure members of
this house will appreciate it would not
be appropriate for me
to comment on an ongoing investigation
and the government has committed to
updating the house in due course mr
speaker i must again point out as i did
in december and i know the house will
also understand that there is a
long-standing practice of successive
administrations that any human resources
matters concerning personnel
relating to individuals does need to
remain
confidential but mr speaker both the
prime minister and i came before this
house in december we set out the details
of the investigation being led by the
cabinet office into these allegations of
gatherings and those investigations are
continuing
let's come to the
deputy leader of the opposition angela
reyna we don't need clapping
thank you mr speaker for granting this
urgent question and it is incredibly
disappointing but not unsurprising that
the prime minister of whom i asked this
question is not here today despite not
having any official engagements and i
think mr speaker his absence speaks
volumes as does he smirks on the media
the public have already drawn their own
conclusions he can run but he can't hide
mr speaker
i received an email this morning from a
man called john who told me on the 20th
of may 2020
i found
my longtime partner dead on the bathroom
floor
i'd been unable to get a gp visit for
her and she had suffered terribly for
some time before the blood clot stopped
her heart
that day
[Music]
the house heard from the prime minister
himself that 181
nhs workers and 131
social care staff had died
many people
made huge personal sacrifices
and the minister quite frankly hides
behind the grey investigation there's no
need for an investigation into the
simple central question today did the
prime minister attend the event in the
downing street garden on the 20th of may
2020
it won't wash mr speaker to blame this
on a few junior civil servants the prime
minister sets the tone
if the prime minister was there
surely he knew exactly the investigation
was sent the invitation was sent to a
hundred staff
many of them his own most
personal senior appointees this was
organized in advance mr speaker so did
the prime minister know about the event
beforehand and did he give his
permission for it to go ahead and if so
did he believe this event was that was
keeping with the restrictions at the
time and the guidelines and was the
chief medical officer consorted before
it went ahead
and what did the chancellor know about
the party given that he lives and worked
next door
and can the minister confirm that no
other ministers were present and finally
mr speaker
can i ask the minister here today
does he still believe the prime minister
to be a man of honor and integrity
[Applause]
mr speaker
her first point was that the prime
minister was not here in person she
knows as well as everyone else in this
house that it is not routine for the
prime minister to answer urgent
questions before this house but
his ministers his ministers are
appointed to do so but he also attends
this house more often than anyone else
to answer questions and we'll be doing
so tomorrow in the normal way at prime
minister's question time
uh
she mentioned the loss of um suffered
the appalling loss suffered by one of
her constituents and my heart goes out
to that constituent and indeed
to all of the others from whom we have
heard in this house on all sides of this
house who have suffered tragic loss as a
consequence of this appalling pandemic
there is a need for an investigation she
said there wasn't
uh there is a need and that need is
clear the investigation is in progress
it's being conducted by someone uh
with whom we have great confidence uh
and a if i can put it this way a paragon
of uh independence and integrity
and in the civil service of
long-standing she is conducting that
investigation and the prime minister
was one was of course himself affected
by the consequence of a covid19
infection
he takes this matter very seriously
as does everyone in government but i
will say this
she asks if i have confidence in the
prime minister's integrity and honor and
i do
so desmond swain
all this should be a powerful corrective
to the urge to order the rest of our
lives shouldn't it
well
we each of us um in this house and no
doubt everywhere else uh live our lives
uh in the best way that we can and those
of us those of us in positions of
responsibility um
acknowledge that responsibility that is
why
there is an investigation in progress uh
which will get to the bottom of all of
these matters and that is in progress
leader of the snp in blackford
thank you mr speaker and can i
congratulate my right honorable friend
for obtaining
this question but mr speaker let's look
around where is the prime minister the
prime minister should be here to answer
these
serious questions where is the
government front bench and indeed
where is the government
mr speaker
this is the most serious of matters
because this is the prime minister who
has been accused
of breaking a law
that he himself said
it could not be more serious and i have
sympathy with the minister who is the
full guy to have to answer this today
the harsh reality mr speaker
is that people around these islands
watched loved ones dying and missing
funerals and the pm and his staff
parted behind the walls of his private
garden mr speaker on that very day on
the 20th of may
there was a tweet from the metropolitan
police reminding people of the
responsibilities you could only meet
with one person outside
the cabinet secretary for culture gave a
press conference at number 10 at 5 pm
reiterating that message there was one
rule for the rest of us
and another rule for those
in number ten now
the minister is seeking to hide behind
the investigation but let me ask the
minister was sue gray one of those
invited to that party on the 20th of may
and did indeed
she attend mr speaker
this is a prime minister
that has lost his moral authority
he doesn't deserve the respect and the
trust of the people of these islands
and if he won't do the decent thing
and recognize that he ought to resign
i say to the minister
and i say to the conservative
backbenchers wherever that they are
going to have to do
what the prime minister has failed to do
and force him from office and do it now
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker well i i don't
accept the characterization that the
honourable right honourable gentleman
puts the same it's clear that in this
country the same rules apply to everyone
and
that is why
that is why there is an investigation in
progress i hope he will not adopt the
approach of questioning the integrity of
uh any civil servant who is
investigating this matter the the
we know
that sue gray is someone who has
conducted previous investigations with
uh thoroughness and vigor
and i think we can rest assured that uh
the result of her inquiry will be in the
public domain in due course but she is a
person of uh integrity and upstanding so
i hope he will not adopt that approach
thank you mr speaker and um
i i does my right honourable friend
agree with me that um it's important
that this place does debate such serious
allegations but that we debate them once
the evidence has been collected
so
i hope that's not a question on me
granting this new queue because that's
loot flag is going i wouldn't go down
that road
[Music]
sorry
sorry mr speaker um
will my vital friend agree with me that
it's important that we have a debate in
this place about these issues once the
uh final uh
recommendations have been put forward by
sue gray because it's important that we
look at the evidence
well i i thank the right-hand lady for
her question and in fact um she is
agreeing i think with the leader of the
opposition
uh because he is the one who said let's
let the inquiry play out
let's see what the findings are
so i think her point is a good one that
um we should wait to see what the result
of this investigation is
rather than
prejudge it
thank you mr speaker
will the minister set out what he thinks
should happen
if a conservative mp is found to have
flouted and broken a covered law
uh it's not for me mr speaker to pass
judgment
or or to pass sentence um first of all
uh the the natural order of justice as
i'm sure he knows is that an
investigation of a fair and impartial
investigation takes place before
there is a a judge jury and executioner
what needs to happen is that
investigation needs to take its natural
course in an orderly way
rather than judge uh guilt or innocence
beforehand
peter bowen
thank you mr speaker i i of course have
great confidence in the prime minister
and the way it's been governing the
country but would the minister agree
with me
that we need the report
urgently in the house so that we can
debate it and reach conclusion i'm
slightly worried mr speaker by the
minister saying that this would have to
be paused if there was a metropolitan
police
investigation is he confident that we
will get a report
before to this house quickly and if he
could give us an indication of when
i
my honourable friend from wellingborough
the prime minister did ask for the
investigation to be conducted swiftly
and i think that is um on the record as
to how long it lasts i don't know
because we have not uh stipulated a time
uh sue gray is conducting this
investigation uh independently of the
executive's directions as he would
expect as the house would expect
we hope for a result swiftly but that
will be a matter for her dear angela
riedel
thank you very much uh mr speaker
perhaps it would be faster
um if sue gray were to investigate the
days that there weren't parties
i have sympathy for the minister because
he's been sent with his gatherings
excuse
to defend the utterly indefensible way
we know do we not mr speaker that an
invite to a bring your own booze party
was sent out for the 20th of may
when
268 people died in hospital on that day
we know that it was illegal to meet
anyone outside of your
own household
except one person overnight so what
is there to wait for the prime minister
should come here now
[Applause]
i i know if i may say so the honorable
lady has an excellent reputation in this
house
amongst other things for fence and i
know that she would want a fair
investigation to take place before any
comment was made so all we are asking to
do is to wait a swift period of time for
the investigation to conclude that is in
the order of uh justice natural order of
fair play
[Music]
thank you mr speaker now this is an
important matter there is absolutely no
doubt about that
but there will be a full investigation
actually into this matter and that is
the most important thing to remember at
this time
does my right honourable friend agree
with me that the time of this house is
better spent at this moment in time as
we recover from the pandemic the time of
this house is better spent debating how
we will build that better and level up
that is what my constituents are looking
for
[Applause]
well she's absolutely right to mention
that it's in the governance of this
country and in the performance of the
executive in delivering
for the people of this country both in
dealing with the existences of this
pandemic but also in matters such as
leveling up it is this government which
is uh performing and which it is
prioritizing so she's right to focus on
that this is of course a matter of
concern to the house and that's accepted
and that is why
we're before the house today but this
matter will be investigated and will
take place uh in the proper order of
events alternate
thank you
mr speaker we know that the prime
minister is socially distanced
from accountability
responsibility and integrity
can we be absolutely sure
that he will be here
tomorrow
to face the music
instead of hiding
behind
well mr speaker no one is hiding the
fact of the matter is that uh the prime
minister will be uh before the house for
prime minister's questions in the normal
course of events and so tomorrow
at this time uh he will be in this
chamber
the reality of the matter is that at the
moment the position is that we are
awaiting the outcome of an investigation
that is in progress so i i know that he
will want to approach this matter
reasonably and that is to wait for the
result of a an investigation
christopher jo
mr speaker why can't all the dirty linen
be washed at once why are we getting
this drip drip
feed
of parties surely the civil service must
have known that there was a party on the
20th of may and they should have
referred that already to the inquiry
minister
well uh mr speaker uh the my honorable
friend makes a good point the reality is
of course that we have a number of dates
that have come out at different times
and that will presumably have an effect
of
delaying matters but
we have commissioned uh the terms of
reference of the investigation that i
think i came before this house on the
9th of december to tell the house about
and that has laid in the libraries of
both houses is that that any dates that
the
the second permanent secretary feels are
appropriate to investigate she will and
i have confirmed to this house that the
15th and 20th of may uh of 2020 are now
amongst those dates
catherine mckinnon
thank you mr speaker
does the pay master general agree with
me that
it would be utterly obscene if at the
same time
oh there's some some phones going on oh
stop carry on sorry
that it would be utterly obscene thank
you mr speaker that if at the same time
that a support group was contacting me
a support group for recovering
alcoholics desperate to meet because
they needed the mutual support to manage
their addiction during the crushing
isolation of lockdown
that staff at number 10 were not only
being encouraged to gather
but were being told to bring their own
booze while doing so
[Music]
i appreciate the prime minister is not
here to answer for his actions but does
the pay master general agree that that
would be obscene
i'm not going to presuppose any
conclusions of the inquiry the inquiry
is taking place even the leader of the
opposition has said that we should let
the inquiry play out we should see what
the findings are and conclusions can be
drawn then
andrew jones thank you mr speaker the
work of the second permanent secretary
of the cabinet office is both important
and urgent can my right-hand friend give
any indication as to when it might be
completed
i can only say that the prime minister's
asked that the inquiry be swift uh and i
have no other indications other other
than that
pete was shot
speaker this isn't the straw that broke
the camel's back this is a tent and
weight being placed directly on the poor
dilapidated piece posterior surely if
the prime minister had a smidgen of
self-respect any sense of integrity he
will be listening to this and he will
decide himself it is time to go for
goodness sake man go
minister
prime minister the prime minister
focuses on the primary purpose of
running this country which is to deliver
to deliver on the manifesto promises of
this government the primary purpose of
this investigation will be to
establish swiftly a general
understanding of the nature of the
gatherings that we've been hearing about
which will include attendance which will
include the setting and the purpose i i
know that the honorable gentleman is
inclined to
presuppose what uh the result of the
investigation will be but the fair
approach would be to wait until the
results of an investigation that has
been commissioned
several
if the prime minister
broke the law he will resign won't he
minister
no it's an entirely hypothetical
position
there is
he he seeks to draw me
he
he the prime minister is going nowhere
the prime he seeks to draw me into
making a supposition about the result of
any inquiry
but the prime minister retains the
confidence of the people of this country
and he did so
two years ago with the biggest majority
in decades
paul
williams
thank you uh mr speaker
a survey by the alzheimer society
showed that the health of 82 percent of
people
affected by dementia deteriorated during
the first lockdown
reduced social contract was a
significant contributory factor
given that does the minister agree that
it would be unforgivable for the prime
minister
to pre-barricate
to obfuscate
to seek to evade
to seek to distract from
to joke about
or even take refuge in an industrial
refrigerator
or perhaps just lie about parties at
number 10.
minister
we'll await the result of the
investigation
thank you mr speaker more than 150 000
kovic deaths the highest toll in europe
a cost of living crisis with universal
credit slashed and bill's rocketing a
second job scandal an attempt to let his
corrupt mate off the hook a dodgy flat
donation and accusations of cash for
access and now this a downing street
party that was against the law which the
prime minister claimed did it happen but
reportedly attended after all of this
does the minister not feel embarrassed
that the prime minister hasn't got the
decency to resign
i would say to the honorable lady that
she is fond of making
unsubstantiated accusations
that are
devoid of evidence
and she should wait in the due course of
events before doing
so she has particularized certain items
which are part of her allegations about
which she has no evidence and she should
be very cautious about doing that
in my
thank you uh mr speaker
the peer master general has been given
an unannounable task this morning it
really really helped but perhaps he
could use
his his experience as a former senator
general and attorney general explained
to the house what advice he would give
to a hypothetical prime minister someone
who perhaps has lied to the country
someone who was perhaps lied to this
house someone who has laughed at times
when people have died in their
communities what advice would the peer
master general offer this hypothetical
prime minister
[Music]
the advice as a law officer that i would
always offer and as i did as a barrister
in practice
is to be fair
to all sides and that in that includes
uh listening to evidence collating
evidence properly
and acting judiciously at all times that
is what we expected this country rather
than prejudging matters and jumping to
unwarranted and unfair conclusions that
applies to justice to all in this
country
thank you mr speaker assaults and police
officers in 2021 in england and wales
saw a 20
increase to over 25 000 and i personally
know of police officers who have been
spat at pushed shoved and punched while
doing their job which includes enforcing
the covert regulations so i think police
officers up and down this country will
be appalled to hear that the prime
minister and dining street staff were
allegedly partying while they were doing
their job during the worst of the
pandemic so given that all the evidence
suggests that this party did take place
and that the prime minister was present
at that party does the paymaster general
agree that the prime minister should
write a letter of apology to every one
of those police officers assaulted
whilst enforcing covert regulations
[Applause]
minister of course as the honourable
lady knows this prime minister has
always been a very strong supporter of
the police as mayor of london unlike the
present incumbent of that office he saw
the reduction
of crime in london as prime minister he
has increased the number of police
officers serving on the streets
this prime minister believes in law and
order he supports the police they know
that in fact he visited a police station
in my constituency in northampton only
last week the prime minister the prime
minister is very supportive of our
police service and will continue to be
i'm so calm
thank you mr speaker
my mom loved mom died i've covered in
march 2020
she died alone in hospital while i sat
in the car outside trying to be as close
to her as i could
even burdened with our grief my family
obeyed the rules just three days after
the dynasty party we mocked a solemn eid
the first without my lovely mom
mr speaker
when asked by sky news about the parties
the prime minister did little but smirk
and laughs
he should be here today
but as he is not can the minister
confirm whether the prime minister will
be apologizing to breed families like
mine for the anguish
pain and torment caused not just by
hosting these parties but for continuing
to lie about it
i think i think the la the the last of
that is not the language of jews and i'm
sure that
i think we could let that one go and i'm
sure the member will want that to stand
back
mr speaker i'm appalled at his tragic
loss and i'm so sorry um to hear about
his mother and my heart goes out to him
and his family
um
the prime minister knows the seriousness
of this disease kovit19 he himself as
the honourable gentleman knows
was in intensive care as a consequence
of it
and he also knows having spoken to
innumerable individuals who have
suffered lost themselves
that
this has resulted in the deaths of many
people in this country and around the
world
he knows that
and he
will never
forget that i ask him to accept my
assurance that the prime minister
is someone for whom
his responsibilities
are writ large
for someone who works hard in the
interests of this country and who
will be subject to sue grey's
investigation together with her inquiry
into all of these parties
so i ask him to wait to see what the
result relatively i presume a relatively
short time
uh until we hear from sucre
thank you mr speaker a constituent of
mine who i'll call malcolm got in touch
this morning having been fined a hundred
pounds of fixed penalty notice for
breaching the coronavirus regulations
now he accepts wrongdoing on his part
however it strikes me it's incredibly
unfair that at the same time as the
downing street parties were happening
and ministers and mps seem to be
flagrantly breaching the rules that
constituents like mine should have to
pay
so i asked the minister when will
malcolm and everyone else who's been
fined for breach of the regulations be
getting their money back
i presume that her constituent together
with others who have been penalized for
breach of the regulations
were duly convicted or either that or
they accepted their responsibility in
the matter what she is doing if i may
say so is prejudging the matter and she
should wait for the result of the
investigation just as presumably as
malcolm did
he'll hammer
thank you mr speaker and there's an
expression the buck stops at the top
that is usually applied by people in
leadership when they take responsibility
in april last year my friend fit ray 58
years old lost his battle with covid and
died
we went to his funeral online via video
link
in august that year my father passed
away and i was fortunate enough to be
able to be in the room with him and hold
his hand as he passed away
in the intervening months between those
two dates i lost count of the amount of
conversations i had with families and
council officers trying to negotiate
more than six or eight people at a
funeral yeah can you please explain
sorry i apologize mr p uh mr speaker can
the pep master general please explain
why
the downing street social world is more
important than those lives
and the law of the land
can i start by saying that i'm very
sorry for his loss of his friend and of
his father
um i think
it would only be fair
to challenge him on his point about what
downing street staff
think
downing street staff worked very hard
for the people of this country and i it
would not be fair to characterize
uh all of all of the work that they have
done over the course of years uh in the
way that he does we don't want to
prejudge what occurred on that occasion
but the reality is we most people i
think we should take the approach uh
unless proven to the contrary that most
people no matter what their party
political persuasion who are in public
life work in the public service and do
the best that they can
thank you mr speaker um
the
the minister has come here today pretty
lonely
uh on his own to deal for the prime
minister with these serious questions
that have
been raised but no self-respecting
minister would come here without knowing
the facts about what
happened and the question here
is simply did the prime minister attend
the gathering on the 20th of may there's
a simple yes or no answer to that i'm
assuming that the minister and coming
here to answer for him has put that
question to the prime minister and knows
the answer he's here to tell this house
can you give the answer to that question
to this house and do so now yeah
minister
that is a matter for sue gray
and her investigation it is not a matter
for me
and the the the government and i am
supported by my colleagues throughout
government in this matter
so tony lloyd
thank you mr speaker on the in around
may the 20th
my life was saved by doctors nurses and
non-medical staff who came forward often
without personal protective equipment
and were prepared to take that risk
because they did their duty does the
payments general honestly believe that
the prime minister's behavior as it is
evidenced in in our newspapers would
give confidence to those people who
saved my life didn't they deserve better
yeah
minister
well prime minister those people who
have served
the people of this country in the
national health service deserve
everything we can give them
so to answer his question of course they
deserve everything we can do to support
them and they get that
they do get that support from this
government but the reality is we
would be wrong to pre-judge and to make
assumptions about what happened on any
given day based on
unknown sources so i think he will wait
um and to find out for sure what
occurred and then
thank you mr speaker during the holy
month of ramadan muslims across all four
nations gather for iftar events to break
their fast and in may 2020 they didn't
in the evenings during ramadan muslims
gather at the mosque to play the rabia
in may 2020 they didn't and an edel
fitter
they play eden amaz together and
celebrate with family and on the 24th of
may 2020 they didn't yet on the 20th of
may just days before eid those who are
making the rules at number 10
were breaking them
so i asked the premaster general if
muslims and people of different faiths
listened to the rules and did not
celebrate religious events then why were
the rules different for those in number
10 for social events
minister
i acknowledge that people of the muslim
faith and indeed of course people of the
christian and hindu and
other faiths jewish faith
all had suffered considerable
interruption to their high holy days i
absolutely accept that and for many
people of strong faith that is very
painful they do so and they did so of
course
and they did so around the world in
other countries too
in the wider public interest to support
the public health of all and they were
asked to do that and they did so in
order to protect their
their fellow citizens
we
respect that and we uh admire that and
we ask people to do that with a heavy
heart that we did so for the best
reasons
richard burton thank you mr speaker mr
speaker the unavoidable truth
is that the public believe the prime
minister is a liar who treats them with
contempt there's a crisis of public
confidence
isn't the only way to restore public
confidence for the prime minister for
once for once to act in the public
interest and resign now
minister
i don't think the public believe what
the honorable gentleman believes
chris
thank you very much mr speaker i've
raised the pay master general when we
had this uq before and i'm grateful mr
speaker for you granting it
i almost missed the birth of my son in
january last year
my wife was nine and a half centimeters
dilated before i was allowed in she was
found in a freezing cold bath having
uncontrolled contractions
we followed the rules to protect
midwifery staff
i have been inundated through the emails
from my own constituents and questions
across the uk since i raised this in the
house before christmas mr speaker
i and many parents
fathers mothers partners would like an
apology from the prime minister
as we followed rules to protect nhs
staff he partied
and the paymaster general should show
some grace
and be upfront with this house about
what he knows because the public really
have had enough
[Applause]
well i'm very sorry that uh he he nearly
missed the birth of his child and i know
that many parents will have actually
uh missed the birth of their children
during the course of this appalling
pandemic
the whole purpose of the investigation
is to establish the facts and if
wrongdoing is established there will be
requisite action
ruth jones
thank you mr speaker and i do thank the
minister for coming to the house today
uh but the people of newport west
expected to see the prime minister
and it's a shame the paymaster general
has to cover for his boss and i do
really feel sorry for him because he has
got a rotten job today mr speaker but
can the minister tell us why anyone in
this house or this country should ever
believe a word the prime minister says
again
mr speaker the prime minister will be
here tomorrow at prime minister's
questions in the normal course of events
and that is more frequent than almost
any other minister
when they appear before this house on
their departmental oral questions so i
think
it is only fair to point out that the
prime minister does answer these
questions himself
i have the support of the entire
government in this matter uh in the in
the limit the answers that i can give
and
my my answers are predicated on the fact
that in the order of natural justice we
wait for the results of the inquiry and
investigation that's taking place that
would be the case with anybody else
that's not special treatment that would
be the case with anybody else against
whom an inquiry is taking place i'm sure
she would accept that casting off
thank you mr speaker i wonder if the
paymaster general can simply clarify for
us has he asked the prime minister about
this party
i i'm not going to disclose personal uh
conversations or otherwise uh it's not
what i will say is that uh that it is my
i am answering the questions on behalf
of the government today and i the
reality the reality is the investigation
will take its course and she will have
answers there mickey foxcroft
thank you mr speaker and my good friend
and constituent will whose father was
ill with cancer only saw him through a
window for his 50th birthday the day
after the downing street party
five weeks later his father sadly passed
away
and only 15 were allowed to the funeral
what does the minister and the prime
minister have to say to will and his
family because quite frankly they feel
like there's one rule for them and
another rule for everyone else
minister
i offer my condolences to her friend and
constituent and her
friend's father for their loss
when i speak
from this dispatch box
i do so
as an individual who understands the
loss that others have suffered we all
know that everyone in this house knows
that we all are equal under the law in
this country
and as a law officer as a law officer i
i recognize that first and foremost she
will no doubt also recognize that in the
interests of fairness uh when inquiry or
investigation is underway it should be
allowed to come to its natural
conclusion
that's char
it pains me about you know the fact that
muslims had to celebrate couldn't
celebrate either family but what pains
me more and really does pay me more
is on the 20th of may one of my
constituents was being buried at
navbar cemetery her daughter maxine
elliott told
the itv today when barbara elliott was
was buried and she was being laid to
rest her and her family were behind
barricades
as the coffin went past
they were only allowed 10 members of the
family and weren't allowed to kiss the
coffin or put a flower on it
all while 40 members of the prime
minister including his prime minister
and his wife organized a party in
downing street gardens so long as though
they bought their own rules
what does the minister have to say to
maxine elliott and will the minister ask
the prime minister himself to personally
apologize to her and her family
the minister well i cannot begin to
imagine the personal
tragedy and loss that she describes
from her
her family and her friends and relatives
and there's no
attempt on my part to try to do so
all i can say is that my heart goes out
to them for their loss
we have had to suffer considerable
imposition in this country as a
consequence of the pandemic but those
impositions have been placed upon
society for good reason and that is to
protect the wider public interest
matt weston
thank you mr speaker this morning i had
a phone call from jill mcculloch in my
constituency
she was so angered by the overnight news
uh and recent reports about these
parties in downing street her father who
had been 100 this year passed away in
the summer of 2020 she was not able to
visit him in may 2020 like so many
people up and down the country she was
abiding by the rules
is it not a simple case that this
government lives by a rule for
themselves and another for the rest of
us
certainly not if that were the case
there would be no investigation
the very fact that there is an
investigation in progress the very fact
that
this matter is in the public domain and
is being inquired into
is a clear indication
that the same rules apply to everyone
ellie reeves
thank you mr speaker when my constituent
gave birth to her first child in may
2020 her husband could only be there for
the final stages of labour and had to
leave two hours after the birth of his
son
mum and baby had to stay in hospital due
to complications and they weren't
allowed any visitors at all she was
lonely and isolated and her baby was
struggling to feed her husband didn't
see the baby again until he was four
days old
my overall friend the member for ogmore
has asked the minister if he will
apologize to the parents of lockdown
babies who did the right thing at great
personal cost whilst number 10 partied
would he now give that apology
i cannot uh prejudge
the investigation
but of course it is a source of
considerable personal regret that anyone
suffers the imposition and inconvenience
and distress
that uh that they have suffered and many
examples have been given in this house
of course that's a matter of personal
regret but uh it's not appropriate to
pre-judge the investigation that's in
progress but if she's asking me to
express my regret
about the
the the tragedy that has befallen all of
those families that have suffered loss
and
and
and
frankly
grotesque
invasions of their family life
then i do so unreservedly
thank you mr speaker
in northern ireland we reached the med
stone of 3 000 deaths due to covert just
last week 3 000 people who
who followed the rules and grave today
so we'll look paymaster i'm putting my
mother-in-law who died alone
well
there will be a film and complete
disclosure tell them in the police
service to the other team almost done
decently i went to the regulations at
the date and at that time i'm sorry mr
speaker
minister
i'm i'm very sorry for his for his loss
mr speaker
he's asking me if um the results of the
investigation will be made public uh and
they will be
thank truly mr speaker i noticed that
the minister conveniently avoided
answering the deputy leader's question
about the chancellor so i'd like to ask
the question again the chancellor was
the next-door neighbor did he know about
the event in downing street on the 20th
of may 2020 and did he attend the event
himself
minister
i do not know and i presume that can be
a question that uh sue grey can inquire
into
thank you mr speaker
page one section c of the ministerial
code says it is of paramount importance
that ministers give accurate and
truthful information in parliament
correcting any inadvertent error at the
earliest opportunity ministers who
knownly misled parliament will be
expected to offer
um resignation to the prime minister
my question to the minister is if the
prime minister knowingly misled
parliament about the existence of this
or any other party will he resign as the
minister of cold says he should
minister there's absolutely no
indication of anything along those lines
so she is mischaracterizing the position
and she's she's jumping the gun so
uh i think it's best not to make
political points but rather to wait for
sue gray's investigation
christine john
thank you very much mr speaker um we've
had today some reminders
of
what so many people in this country were
going through in may
2020 one of the things which helped keep
us all together was the belief
that we were all in it together and the
government understood and supported what
we were going through yep
can the pay master general tell us
whether the prime minister appreciates
that now
my constituents and i'm sure
constituents elsewhere in the country
feel let down
betrayed and treated with contempt
by this prime minister and his
government and can he tell us when he
will show some respect for the house and
come here and answer the questions we
all have for him
[Music]
minister prime minister will come to
this house tomorrow at prime minister's
questions and the leader of the
opposition or his deputy will have the
opportunity to ask questions then
she asks whether we're all together yes
we are all in this together
and the prime minister knows as prime
minister he sees the
the documents he sees the scientists he
sees the medical professionals he meets
he meets the families he visits around
the country he's in a better position
than most to know the impact of this
pandemic
and he fully recognizes not only because
of his personal experience but because
of what he has seen and witnessed uh by
his visits and by his meetings and by
everything else that he's done as prime
minister since this cove pandemic began
he does recognize that he's on the side
of the people of this country and he's
working to achieve the best results for
the people of this country julie elliot
thank you mr speaker
many thousands of families during this
pandemic have suffered when loved ones
have been in hospital having surgeries
operations without the benefit of their
families nothing to do with culverd but
an impact of the restrictions my family
have been through that my brother was in
hospital in may 2020 and i couldn't
visit him he sadly died in april 2021
and again we could only visit him in the
last hours of his life what my family
have suffered is no different than many
thousands across this country we stuck
to the rules we did what was expected
and to to find out through the press
that the prime minister the downing
street were partying at those times made
me feel stick to the stomach and i felt
it to content for what their behavior
when will the prime minister come to
this house confess what has happened and
take responsibility for the actions
under his watch in downing street and
sometimes saying sorry
is good but is not enough
minister the prime minister will be here
tomorrow mr speaker as i've said in the
normal course of events and he will
continue to represent the government of
this country and recognizes better than
anyone uh the impact of this appalling
pandemic on the people of this country
thank you very much mr speaker we work
within a system where the prime minister
appoints the independent adviser and the
prime minister is responsible for
applying the ministerial code but this
prime minister has demeaned his position
of becoming a law unto himself he
refuses to observe the nolan principles
so who amongst us government is going to
be brave enough to tell this prime
minister the party is finally over
minister well he makes those
accusations
uh they're not supported by the evidence
and he should wait to see what the
result of the investigation is
the prime minister acknowledges the
importance of the nolan principles in
public life and he adheres to them
sometime
thank you mr speaker in december the
prime minister said and i quote i can
understand how infuriating it must be to
think the people who have been setting
the rules have not been following rules
because i was also furious
i can only think mr speaker that his own
cabinet and ministers must be furious
given so few of them showing up here
today supported in the same way perhaps
a rope supports a hanging man i think
who else was furious my constituents
churchgoers unable to go to church at
easter
muslims unable to go to the mosque and
to celebrate eid with their own families
my local muslim burial ground often at
times unable to
dig the graves fast enough to put the
bodies into it in redbridge
when will the prime minister mr speaker
use his next address to the nation to
apologize to each and every one of those
families for his disgraceful rule
breaking that has left not only this
government devoid of any support amongst
the british public but it's harming our
democracy itself
well as i've already said and i'll
repeat that those who
were unable to celebrate the high holy
days of their religion
suffered a terrible imposition
whether that was easter the christian
community or eid or passover
and
one can only express
um sorrow that that has had to happen
but it's had to happen in countries
around the world
because of the exigencies of the
pandemic
the prime minister is carrying on the
business of government as my fellow
ministers are
and will continue to do so
i'll listen mcgovern
thank you mr speaker now thank you for
granting this important urgent question
and the minister won't think me fair and
he'll go on about process
but i have to say having listened to
what everybody has said about what their
constituents have been through i think
coming here with not a single answer to
a single question is the height of
disrespect
so can i ask mr speaker a question a
simple one one that will be easy for the
minister to answer that he must know
when will this investigation be over
minister well i think the honourable
lady is fair i'm sure she is fair
um and
she knows i think she does clearly know
that no disrespect
is intended um but what she doesn't
recognize is that what is also fair
is the proper administration of justice
and one of those one of those
fundamental tenets a pillar of fairness
is to allow investigations to continue
she wishes to pre-judge she wishes to
cast stones before she knows what has
exactly happened uh the fair thing to do
would be to await the result of any
investigation that has been commissioned
thank you uh mr speaker if ever there
was a time to be candid with this house
it's now and i'm asking the payer
master's general a question of him not
of anybody else he didn't answer my old
friend from garson hill which i'll give
another go
has the pay master general been told
whether the prime minister attended the
downing street party on the 20th of may
or not
if so
what was the answer
minister i am not going to discuss what
uh
with this in this house what private
conversations take place between
government ministers uh i know my duty
to this house and the the reality of the
matter is he wishes to pre-judge the
matter he's wrong to do so
it is not a matter for me i am not
conducting the inquiry it is a matter
for sue gray
sue gray and her team will be
investigating the matter and will come
to the due conclusion he should wait
patiently for that i don't know when
that i think his predecessor question
was about when that answer will come i
don't know the answer to that but we
have asked that it be done swiftly and
as soon as that is possible it will be
given
a check
mr speaker i was pleased to hear the pay
master general tell us earlier that the
prime minister has recently visited a
police station
i hope he'll be visiting another one
soon this time
with the benefit of his solicitor but i
want to return to the issue of fixed
penalty notices that was raised by
another honourable member
because last april the joint committee
on human rights we issued a report
saying that the fixed penalty notices
issued during the height of the crisis
which could be as much as 10 000 pounds
were muddled discriminatory and unfair
now this incident which is currently
being investigated and i use the word
advisedly really only goes to show that
we were right in our concerns about
unfair enforcement of the rules
during the pandemic and i think the pain
master general acknowledged earlier as
you would expect from a former law
officer
that one of the most important
principles to a democracy is the
principle of equality before the law
so will the government now commit to a
review of all the fixed penalty notices
that were issued
during the height of the crisis as
recommended in our report
and will the government consider pardons
for those who have been held to a higher
standard than those who govern us
minister
surely she would know mr speaker about
the pillars of fair
justice and she knows that it's
necessary to wait for the result of the
investigation she would know that better
than most
as for the enforcement of rules
they apply equally to everyone in this
country and they have done for many
generations and they will continue to do
so barbara keeley
thank you mr speaker in may 2020 a
constituent told me this
i had a little baby boy on the 17th of
april but because of pandemic conditions
we have been unable to have anyone round
not friends nor family we're completely
on our own
it's been really hard my dad hasn't met
his grandson and i'm feeling
exceptionally isolated and alone without
any support
how does the minister feel how does he
himself feel about the behavior of the
prime minister and downhill street staff
enjoying a drinks party while new
mothers like my constituent felt
unsupported and desperately alone
i can tell the honourable lady how i
feel about what has happened to her
constituents and as a human being
i feel considerable regret and sorrow
and indeed distress for those who have
suffered loss of course i do we all do
we would not be human if we didn't so i
say to her
i'm
terribly sorry for the loss of her
constituents friends and families and
for everybody who suffered loss but my
feelings
are irrelevant
what matters is the opinion of those who
have been charged with the heavy duty of
investigating
the propriety of gatherings that may or
may not have taken place when that
person then reports back
on the result of their investigations
then no doubt the honourable lady will
wish to discuss the matter further dame
diana johnson
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
general has made um various references
to fairness and justice natural justice
today he's made no reference at all to
the nolan principles the seven standards
that govern us all in public life
including honesty leadership and
accountability
so on that basis why will the prime
minister not do what gavin barwell a
former chief exec chief of staff in
number 10 has suggested and come clean
and say whether he attended that party
or not why is he hiding behind sue
gray's investigation
minister
mr speaker no one is hiding behind
anything um the the fact is the prime
minister will be here at pmq's tomorrow
as i've already said
um the investigation uh is one
you know free of any favor um or fear uh
it is taking place impartially and will
produce an equitable result and when we
know what that result is we'll be able
to comment further but we mustn't
prejudge
uh the matter i think i did actually
refer to the nolan principles in an
answer to a question from the scottish
nationalists but what i what i know is
that the prime minister respects those
seven principles of public life
um and that he adheres to them he's
served in the public
realm
for many years as mayor of london as a
member of parliament as prime minister
before that as foreign secretary i know
the prime minister
and i know that he is a man of integrity
and he wishes to conduct himself
appropriately what will happen uh will
be that in the normal course of events
the senior civil servant
um
and the civil service is an entity that
we all respect in this country the
senior civil servant who has been
charged with an independent assessment
of this matter will report in due course
thank you mr speaker my constituent
alison lather who is a nurse in the icu
at the whittington hospital tragically
left her role
wanting to go to the funeral of her
grandmother but couldn't get there for
covert reasons
will he give a message to allison who
works day in day out to look after covid
patients the whittington hospital having
had one of the highest numbers of covid
cases last week what does he say to her
and to her family that she had to watch
her grandmother's funeral on zoom
while she slaved
and they over there partied with their
bring your own booze party it's an
absolute disgrace
minister i can only offer my condolences
to her constituent for
their terrible loss and i offer those
condolences and through her to her
constituent
go around davis thank you
mr speaker at the time of the number 10
danny street party
people in swansea in wales could face
fines between 60 pounds and 1009
pounds for holding similar events
doesn't this show to respect the welsh
labour government holds for the public
health of their citizens in contrast to
the contempt that the the prime minister
holds and given he must know whether he
actually was at the party why won't he
simply say that why should we wait for
inquiry to find out what he already
knows why is he hiding the truth
minister uh it would be inappropriate to
make a running commentary on an
investigation that is in progress
and uh we will continue to await the
result of the investigations undertaken
by sue gray hello page
thank you very much mr speaker my
constituent ruby fuller was a remarkable
young woman who'd been head girl at the
charter school in dullich and lived by
her motto live kindly live loudly in
pursuit of her passion for social
justice she had many many friends
ruby died aged 18 from non-hodgkin's
lymphoma on the 15th of may the same day
that the prime minister sat enjoying
cheese and wine in the downing street
garden and five days before a hundred
staff were invited to bring your own
booze party
ruby's friends had to say goodbye on
zoom and her family were allowed just 10
people at her funeral what does the
prime minister
via his minister
have to say to ruby's family
and her friends young people in my
constituency who should have confidence
in their government who are looking at
the evidence in front of them in plain
sight and seeing that it is one rule for
them and another for everyone else
[Music]
mr speaker what the prime minister would
say and what i say
um is that
the motto that um ruby
she says lived by live kindly and live
loudly
um to lose
to lose such a young
life at such a tragic age in such
appalling circumstances
is a sorrow that those who loved her
will never be able to get over
there's nothing that i can say that will
ameliorate that
but what i can say is that both the
prime minister and i and the entire
government would offer our condolences
for their loss
and would say that um in the short life
that she lived if she made people around
her happy
um
she is someone who will be remembered
throughout her friends and family's
whole lives
thank you mr speaker does the minister
agree that every moment that goes by
with the government of the united
kingdom unable to say where the prime
minister of the united kingdom was on
may the 20th
makes the government more and more of a
laughingstock and undermines the
critical public health messages on which
so many lives depend and will he
apologize to the heroes of the nhs such
as those at newcastle hospitals trust
who spent hours and hours in full ppe
working exhausting and offering
traumatic shifts
and yet managed to keep lockdown rules
well the prime minister has personally
thanked
all of those who have worked to protect
people during this pandemic and will
continue to do so and the prime minister
has visited hospitals he's spoken to
medical professionals doctors nurses
scientists
and those directly involved and has
repeatedly thanked them and and feels
that thankful thankfulness from the
bottom of his heart and he himself of
course was served
as at st thomas's hospital uh by medical
professionals who helped save his life
when he was admitted to intensive care
he knows that first hand
what's in docker cabinet office minister
michael ellis uh really facing an
absolute grilling in the comments from
the opposition benches uh an urgent
question called by the labor party
angela um eagle uh spoke there as well
uh earlier
the government he says
will answer these questions boris
johnson is not there today he repeatedly
said that boris johnson would be at
prime minister's questions tomorrow but
real anger from the other side we have
uh moving moments moments of absolute
raw grief when the dup minister
broke down in tears talking about his
stepmom
passing away jim shannon also enormous
anger calls for apologies for people
working in the emergency services for
the police forces calls for apologies
for people who weren't able to celebrate
religious events also calls for refunds
for people who uh
faced charges and were charged and fined
over breaching covert regulations
um a lot of emotion and a lot of anger
there in the comments uh let's talk to
emma jones uh she's been watching this
coverage um she's somebody with a
particular view on this she lost her 18
year old daughter ruby to cancer just
before this happened on the 15th of may
emma thank you so much for talking to us
today um
what are your feelings today i mean
clearly anger in the house of commons
about this
about the fact that there appears to
have been a party uh for up to 100
people five days after your daughter
passed away
yes well i think
there have been so many of these now um
and
it's just it's incredibly insulting and
i think it just makes a very horrible
situation
just that bit worse
um and i think what's particularly
infuriating now is that the evidence is
really mounting
and it really feels as though it's time
for the prime minister to just put his
hand up and accept and acknowledge that
what they did was wrong and it was it
was very very wrong and it was very very
insulting to all those people all those
families like ourselves who made
enormous sacrifices and whose end of
life was made that much more painful
because of the restrictions
tell us what the last
few days were like with your daughter
so maybe she didn't die of covid she
died of blood cancer and she'd been
treated for about 10 months most of
which was as an inpatient in hospital
and until three weeks before she died we
thought she was going to get better
but she came home um
from hospital at the end of february and
then was under regular checkups and did
a checkup on the 23rd of april they
found that the cancer had come back and
by that stage she was out of options
before she got sick she was a perfectly
healthy happy teenager halfway through
her sixth form
and with plans to go out and save the
world so on the 23rd of april she she
found out that the cancer had come back
we knew she was going to die we didn't
know how long it would take as it turns
out it was very quick it was only three
weeks later that she died
we were lucky in that she was at home so
she was able to be with me and her
father and her sister but we were the
only people other than hospice care
staff who came in to look after her who
she could see during that time so she
couldn't see her friends she couldn't
see her grandparents
they had to say goodbye to her on zoom
[Music]
and we did that because those are the
rules it was a really really strict time
of lockdown then you could only meet one
person outside
and we followed the rules because it was
really important
and we didn't begrudge doing that
because we knew it was it was what
everybody had to do there were no
exceptions
and now it would appear that those rules
were for everybody except for
um the government except for number 10
and it's just
so maddening that they weren't following
their own rules it makes me very very
cross you seem really calm about it i'm
not quite sure i'd be quite as calm as
you are being um
how hard was it for you you've lost your
daughter i mean this is the wrong order
of things isn't it and presumably you
weren't able to be around your parents
to comfort you
yes absolutely i mean
the pain of losing a child is is
indescribable is i think it's the worst
worst pain anyone can go through
and it was painful for so many people it
was extremely painful for my parents and
for her friends and the fact that we
couldn't come together we couldn't come
together to comfort each other just made
it a lot worse it was excruciating
how was the funeral
so we actually chose not to have a
funeral so ruby had been very organized
in her last three weeks
she left us a list of things she wanted
us to do
and she said actually when it came to a
funeral she wasn't bothered by what we
did she said i'm not going to be there i
want you to do whatever works best for
you
and we felt because the rules at the
time were a maximum of 10 people
socially distanced we didn't feel that
would offer any comfort or solace to
anyone i didn't want to put ruby's
sister through that i didn't want to put
my parents through that
so we thought we'd wait until we could
do something later on and then we
quickly realized that was we were going
to be waiting a long time so we ended up
doing three very tiny events when the
rules were relaxed to allow six people
to come together
um but it was it wasn't the big
coming together the big celebration of
life that we'd hoped for and i think
that has made the grieving process a lot
harder for everybody not just for us
and when you think back now to that time
and how incredibly difficult
it was for you
um what would your message to the
government be today
well my message would be
i think you owe us an apology it's very
very clear that you broke the rules
it would appear that you don't care that
you broke the rules and i feel very
strongly that we deserve leaders who
will lead by example
we deserve better than this and it's
funny that you said i i seem very calm
about this i am boiling with rage inside
and if ruby were alive now she would be
absolutely spitting mad
she asked to be remembered by the motto
live kindly live loudly she believes
that being kind
is the most important thing but she also
believed very strongly in calling out
injustice and standing up for what you
believe in which is where the loudly
part of her motto comes from
and she would not be calm if she was
allowed alive right now she would have
made a protest banner and she'd be
banging on the gates of number 10 and
absolutely furious
so i'm doing this interview for her this
is me living loudly on her behalf
because she would want me to talk up
about this
do you think the government is operating
to a different set of rules
than the ones that you operated to
absolutely absolutely i think it was
mentioned by somebody just now in the
houses of parliament it's one rule for
them one rule for everybody else and
that's just not acceptable it's not good
enough
it's frankly outrageous and it's time
for them to to confess and and to
apologize
how hard was it for you to stick to the
rules i mean obviously you did um
but there must have been moments when
you just thought i i really want my
parents around me now or
ruby really deserves to have her friends
around her now
yes i mean it was very hard thank
heavens for technology um and actually
the fact that um so ruby should have
been taking her a-levels that summer and
the fact that for her friends you know
it was the first year where all the
exams were cancelled so
had there been exams her friends would
have literally just been starting to set
their a level exams as she died as it
was they weren't sitting exams so they
were available
to talk to her a lot on zoom there were
a lot of online house parties that she
took part in so she was able to be
connected with her friends but it's just
not the same as seeing people in person
and it was it was very hard what we did
after she died is we actually created a
bit of a
memorial garden in our front garden with
banners and flowers and we invited
people to come past and leave little
notes about what they remember
remembered about ruby and that became a
very beautiful thing so people came
through in their family groups in pairs
under the rules
but there was a constant stream of
people coming through our front garden
which was really the best the best that
we could do the best that we could offer
people under the circumstances
well emma thank you for for talking to
us today and telling us all about ruby
and i'm really sorry for your loss thank
you very much
well let's get more reaction to this now
with dr salia
who's worked in icu during the pandemic
and also
lost her father to covert during this
time and great to talk to you today
doctor you were watching uh that
coverage
in parliament uh your reaction when you
saw that
dup minister break down in the commons
you know that that reaction is i think
echoed across the country there are over
150 000 families now who have lost loved
ones we've hit that milestone
um i felt
empathy with the politician who broke
down in tears
i myself lost my father we have only
just reached the first year anniversary
of his death from covid in fact today
would have been him and my mother's 52nd
wedding anniversary so there's a lot of
pain associated with what's going on and
you know these
revelations that we are hearing almost
on a weekly basis
yeah we had a break for christmas um a
new year but they're back and who knows
how much more will come but each time
we learn something new
our pain and our wounds that we are
trying to get through and our grieving
process is impacted
and we're bracing ourselves for more
so you're saying that that the news that
you're hearing is actually making your
grief worse
absolutely we're still trying to heal
the grieving process for the families
that have lost loved ones to covert
uh has been challenging because there
are so many unknown entities there are
so many questions and we need answers
and that's why an inquiry an independent
inquiry into the way that the government
managed covert in this country is so
critical and so crucial thank goodness
we now finally have a chair appointed
and the process will begin soon i hope
but
this drip feed of revelations of what
we're learning is painful but crucially
important it kind of is like the warm up
to the to the main act i think because i
think
yes what we're learning now is terrible
but what more is to come and only when
this is done and dealt with and out
there and there has been proper
accountability will we then finally be
able to heal it won't happen until then
what were the restrictions like around
the time that your dad died and and how
did they affect
how much time you were able to to be
with him
so let's let's go back to may when when
this alleged party took place and the
invitations were sent out and
you know this wasn't a a knee-jerk let's
get together
this was a pre-meditated arranged
gathering with invitations of up to 100
sent out at the same time as
the rest of us were being told um by
politicians advised by their scientific
advisors that only we could only meet
one person at a time so at the time of
the party the alleged party
restrictions were pretty fierce and
let's go back to remind ourselves of the
environment that we were living in we
were in the pre-k we were in the
pre-vaccine days
medics and scientists not just in the uk
but around the globe we're still trying
to work out how this virus is really
impacting us we were still trying to
work out within hospitals what the
correct ppe measures were we were having
our pp i i at that time was working
emergency medicine within a e moving
into intensive care we were at that
point still trying to work out the safe
ways of working within hospitals staff
members my colleagues were living in
tents outside their own homes for fear
of passing on infection my questions as
a doctor
and as a member of the public anna's
someone who has lost a loved one to
covert and knows the reality of how
easily the disease was being transmitted
last year
and still continues to be
that but with now with the caveat of
safety measures in place the vaccine and
face masks at that point we didn't have
that all so strictly in place so i want
to know how many infections did these
gatherings arranged by uh 10 downing
street and by
the various offices within government
how many how much more infection spread
did that lead to and my other question
is this
uh
this is a finite group of people
people are in the know whenever you have
a community or a group of people people
tend to know what's going on how many
people who are speaking to us on a daily
basis from their podiums from number 10
knew about these things so once they on
the one hand were telling us scientific
evidence says that we are now going down
to only one you can only meet one person
at the time uh to ensure correct safety
measures with uh uh
with kerbin covered spread how many of
them knew about these gatherings how
many had that email sitting in their
inbox during the day when they came to
speak to us in the evening these are all
questions that need answering and the
only people that will be able to
investigate this properly are the police
and in terms of your dad you you know
you're saying that you were renee at
that time but many of your siblings are
also doctors as well aren't they how did
that affect your ability to be with your
dad
during that period of time my brother
actually caught covid from working
within hospitals so in april last year
myself and my brother were holed up in a
flat um
being very ill and and and isolating
when we were covered and bearing mine he
caught it from hospital from work
um in may when we emerged and we were
going out and about
we were then terrified about going
anywhere near my father um five of us
are doctors we didn't go we we reduced
our contact with our father who was left
alone for the majority of time during
that year we were
torn between
looking after our patients on the front
line and doing now atmos to what we
signed up for which is essentially
caring for others um to then neglecting
our own father it was a really
challenging year really really
challenging but we did what we had to do
ultimately he did catch covert at the
end but what is really painful
is that we spent so much time away from
him
because those were the rules and we knew
that those were the correct rules
because uh any form of contact could
have
given him uh
the virus
and so many other people were sticking
to the walls because not only were they
worried about themselves they were
worried about others
i feel that the thursday night clapping
that was being that was taking place on
this on the steps of number 10 it was
just a mockery there was so
this whole episode smacks
of disrespect to those of us that were
working on the front line a lack of
respect and understanding for those of
us that lost loved ones and i fear that
there is more to come
dr dr salia assange we're going to have
to leave it there uh really good to talk
to you thank you for talking to us about
your experience and the loss of your dad
as well
you're watching sky news today coming up
next with sarah jane me boris johnson
under fire over the revelations about a
downing street party held during the
height of lockdown
[Music]
you